I understand that you are talking to us
from where are you you're in Egypt yes
Alexandria Egypt you're in Alexandria
Egypt I've never been to Egypt tell me a
little bit about yourself
um
um I'm 22 years old I am an Mis student
like a debt analysis student oh data
analysis okay and uh that's it I'm I'm
married a bit young but I am married
already oh you're married uh tell us a
little bit about who you married I met
my wife playing Among Us funnily enough
wait that's a video game Among Us right
I've played I've played that game I've
played that game with my kids where you
need to
someone is the traitor is that right
someone is the the bad guy and you don't
reveal who you are and and uh so you
that's how you met your wife that's how
I got married this is 2022. how you meet
your wife okay
uh this is a covid marriage
um so you were playing online yes and we
played yes we played online we had this
one round where it was only me her and
one more person left and I was an
imposter I was killing everyone and this
person caught me uh as I killed someone
and he thought it was her and she was so
adorable and like desperate to defend
herself but that was like okay I'm the
Imposter I can't anymore oh oh my God
wait a minute so you gave up your chance
to win the game because you were in love
with this virtual person yes I had a
bigger plan in mind from this point on
that is a really good thing that's a
very inspiring story I mean how did you
try that in real life where you go kill
people and then you suddenly are like
I'm not gonna do it let's get married
well first of all true story my wife
walked in on me as I was finished
murdering three people and she and then
I turned to her and then I realized I
loved her and uh dropped the knife and
we went off and got married changed your
ways it changed my way well no I
continued to murder long after that I
apologize it's very profitable
um uh I want to make sure I see your
name moataz right
um it's close or or is that how I say it
mohitas
there's a sound
yeah I want to get it just right listen
I am saying again and make me say it
correctly it's your job you have to make
me say it it's it's
yes
hey nice job
okay I am Conan oh no you can't make
okay I tried to make my name like hard
to say and exotic and I failed I
apologize so this is fascinating you met
your wife online playing the video game
Among Us
um so does she live in Alexandria as
well no she is German she is in Germany
yeah yeah we're we're married
I'm sorry I'm thinking the same thing I
thought maybe you you met her online and
just both decided to be married and
you've never met her you've actually
been officially married oh anyone can
buy a ring dude like me yeah they I
bought I've had plenty of these
this doesn't prove a thing I wore these
when I was single because the ladies
will like it have you met my wife
neither have I
so uh so you meet her online she's from
Germany did you then fly to Germany to
go see her no she came over I was still
studying so she had to come over she's
working uh she came over in early 2021
where we spent like a week or so
together and then she flew back I
finished my semester and then she came
back again for two weeks or so we got
married she met my family all my gosh
wow this isn't this is a great story
yeah so you this is a real love that
formed online playing this game then she
comes over to Alexandria and that's a
lot of pressure because you must be
thinking I liked her online when we were
playing among us but what if I don't
like her when she's hanging out in
Alexandria for a week but you hit it off
right away yes in the first week I I as
soon as I knew her I was like yes this
is the woman oh that makes me so happy
that makes me so happy does she live
with you now in Alexandria no no as soon
as I finish my studying I'm traveling to
Germany as soon as I'm done with my
studies okay so she's in Germany and
you're here when are you going to be
done with your studies uh about mids
2023 I think okay good good uh I I don't
want to delay this you know it's
important it's important to be together
you know it's uh very important I didn't
mean to do that
it's important to be together
well I don't have a lot of experience
um what do you think it works I'm not
sure these kids these kids just arrived